From PRI, Public Radio International.
来自PRI，公共广播国际。
So Sandra thought she knew how to beat the system. She thought she knew how to get her name into the art magazines, and be respected, and be quoted, and be looked up to, just like Laurie Anderson. Here was her scheme. She had her piano set up next to the Harbor Freeway in Los Angeles at rush hour.
桑德拉曾以为她知道如何打破常规。她以为自己知道如何让自己的名字出现在艺术杂志上，受到尊重，被引用，并像劳里·安德森一样受人敬仰。这是她的计划。在洛杉矶高峰时段，她把钢琴架在了海港高速公路旁边。
And that is a super-congested part of the freeway, and it was on the afternoon of Labor Day weekend, on Friday.
那是高速公路上交通极其拥堵的地段，时间是劳动节周末的周五下午。
And you were on the median of the freeway there, right?
你当时是在高速公路的中央隔离带上，对吧？
I wanted to be, but I ended up-- I couldn't get permission for that-- on a parking lot that just abutted the freeway with a third of the amplification they use in U2 concerts. Marshall Stax next to me just booming out over eight lanes of freeway.
我本来想在那儿，但最后没能获准——我是在紧邻高速公路的一个停车场，用的扩音设备是U2演唱会的三分之一。马歇尔音箱就在我旁边，对着八车道的高速公路轰鸣。
It got her attention, but not the right kind, not the Laurie Anderson, someday you will meet Lou Reed kind.
这确实引起了关注，但不是那种正确的关注，不是那种“劳里·安德森，总有一天你会遇到卢·里德”式的关注。
I had come into this trying to just be a performance artist in the Italian futurist, Dadaist style. I was in my 20s and reading those kinds of materials about those types of artists, which always makes you want to run out and do guerrilla art. And so that's what I thought I was doing, but in fact, after I did the first event, it became this huge media blitz with People magazine and all that kind of stuff.
我刚开始时只是想成为一名意大利未来主义、达达主义风格的表演艺术家。那时候我才20多岁，读了这类艺术家的材料，这总是让人想冲出去搞游击艺术。所以我以为我做的是那个，但实际上，在第一次活动之后，它演变成了一场《人物》杂志等媒体参与的巨大宣传闪电战。
There were jokes about you on The Tonight Show .
《今夜秀》里还有关于你的笑话。
Exactly, and CNN, AP, Newswire, whatever.
没错，还有CNN，美联社，新闻专线，等等。
Now, this brings us to the theme of today's program. From WBEZ in Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, we choose some topic, invite various writers, performers, and documentary producers to tackle that topic. Today on our program, four stories about people struggling at the very margins, the very edges of our nation's media, music, infotainment, newsfotainment, industry complex. Act One, How to Get Famous. Act Two, Whoring in Commercial Radio News. It's a story by Scott Carrier. Act Three, Doing a Personal Act for Money. Act Four, Lifestyles of the Rich and Famous. Stay with us.
现在，这引出了我们今天节目的主题。从芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请不同的作家、表演者和纪录片制作人来探讨这个主题。今天在我们的节目中，有四个关于人们在国家媒体、音乐、信息娱乐、新闻娱乐产业复合体的边缘挣扎的故事。第一幕，如何出名。第二幕，商业广播新闻中的“卖身”。这是斯科特·卡里尔的故事。第三幕，为钱做个人表演。第四幕，富人和名人的生活方式。请继续收听。
Act One, How to Get Famous. So Sandra Tsing Loh is now a writer. Now she's a regular contributor here on This American Life . Now she's author of a new book. Now she was star of a one-woman show that got rave reviews this summer.
第一幕，如何出名。桑德拉·清·罗现在是一位作家。她是《美国生活》的常驻撰稿人。她是新书的作者。今年夏天，她主演的单人秀获得了好评。
But back in the 1980s before she became the master of all media, she lived this little parable of fame in America. After her first media success, after she did the big thing by the highway and was featured in every media outlet, everybody who she knew became an expert and told  her to hire a publicist. A publicist would cost $1,000 a month. And Sandra thought about this and figured she could get just as much publicity, she thought, if she would just give away $1,000 in $1 bills as she played the piano. And to test this scientific theory, she schemed out a second public event, which she called, self-promotion.
但在20世纪80年代，在她成为全媒体大师之前，她经历了这则关于美国名利的小寓言。在她获得第一次媒体成功后，在她在高速公路旁搞了大新闻并登上各大媒体之后，她认识的每个人都成了专家，并告诉她要雇一个公关。一个公关每月要花费1000美元。桑德拉想了想，觉得如果她在弹钢琴时把1000美元以1美元纸币的形式送出去，她也能获得同样的宣传效果。为了验证这个科学理论，她策划了第二个公开活动，她称之为“自我推销”。
She had intended this title ironically. The event was supposed to be a critique of self-promotion, but nobody took it that way.
她本来是讽刺性地使用这个标题的。这个活动本应是对自我推销的批判，但没人把它看作那样。
So of course, in fact, a crowd did appear. All the news stations showed up, and did this actually very beautiful piece of videotape of me playing the piano. And then, my assistant who was handcuffed to his briefcase, threw the $1,000 in $1 bills over me, and they floated in the air. And you saw all these hands in the air, reaching up, and then the wind shifted and carried the bills about two feet the other way. And all the hands shifted after the bills, much like underwater sea creatures. It was really quite beautiful. And I got, in fact, a bit trampled, which was my point. I thought it was a morality tale in Los Angeles that if you pay people to come and see you, they've just come to see the money. So when the money comes, they will grab for the money, and the artist is trampled underneath.
所以当然，事实上，人群确实出现了。所有的电视台都来了，还拍下了我弹钢琴的非常美丽的录像带。然后，我的助手被铐在公文包上，把1000张1美元的钞票撒在我身上，它们在空中飘浮。你可以看到空中所有的手都在向上抓，然后风向变了，把钞票吹到了两英尺外的另一个方向。所有的手都跟着钞票移动，就像水下的海洋生物一样。这真的很美。实际上我还有点被踩踏，这正是我的目的。我认为这是一个在洛杉矶的道德故事：如果你付钱让人来看你，他们只是来看钱的。所以当钱出现时，他们会抢钱，而艺术家则被踩在脚下。
Do you think that actually people got that message?
你认为人们真的理解了那个信息吗？
No, and I knew for sure that they didn't get it, because driving from that event, I heard a live KNX Newsradio broadcast that said, "We just got reports that performer Sandra Loh, an aspiring actress in Hollywood, did this publicity stunt so that she can try to get parts in movies." So in other words, no matter what you do as a performance artist, I had this naive notion that I was a cutting edge Dadaist or one of the yippies making happenings and living theater stuff happening. When, in fact, the media story would always be reduced to struggling performer trying to get noticed in Hollywood. That's the only story that applies to any of this.
没有，我确定他们没理解，因为从那个活动开车回来时，我听到KNX新闻广播的现场直播说：“我们刚刚接到报道，好莱坞的抱负女演员、表演者桑德拉·罗搞了这次宣传噱头，是为了能在电影中获得角色。”所以换句话说，无论作为表演艺术家你做什么，我曾天真地认为自己是前卫的达达主义者或者像那些嬉皮士一样制造事件和生活剧。但事实上，媒体报道总是被简化为“苦苦挣扎的表演者试图在好莱坞引起注意”。这是唯一适用于所有这些情况的故事。
From her experience, years later, she actually wrote a little primer on how to get famous. She says that there's something called the wacky news circuit, and the wacky news circuit will pick up your story if you stage an odd event that provides sensational video on a slow news day, at a time and location convenient to reporters and TV crews. She says it helps if you do it in Hollywood, which is the capital of wacky news, or in front of a symbolic national monument.
多年后，根据她的经验，她实际上写了一本关于如何出名的小入门书。她说有一种东西叫“古怪新闻循环”，如果你策划一个奇怪的事件，在新闻平淡的日子里，在方便记者和电视摄制组的时间和地点提供耸人听闻的视频，古怪新闻循环就会采用你的故事。她说，如果你在古怪新闻之都好莱坞做这件事，或者在具有象征意义的全国性纪念碑前做，会有帮助。
The wacky news circuit is-- at the time that I was doing my freeway piano piece, there was a guy who could paint sunsets in five minutes and had a very funny rap about that. There was a doctor who claimed that he knew what sounds dinosaurs made, which was a great radio story blurb. And there were these racing pigs in Iowa. They raced pigs in Iowa and fed them Oreo cookies to keep them going around the track.
古怪新闻循环是——在我做高速公路钢琴表演的时候，有一个人可以在五分钟内画出日落，并且对此有非常有趣的即兴说唱。有一位医生声称他知道恐龙发出的声音，这是一个很棒的广播故事预告。还有爱荷华州的赛猪。他们在爱荷华州赛猪，并喂它们奥利奥饼干让它们绕着赛道跑。
Now, these were the stories that were on the wacky news circuit the same week you were with that piece.
现在，这些就是你做那个表演的同一周里在古怪新闻循环上的故事。
Exactly.
没错。
That's that particular week.
就是那一周。
Right. It's like an affable eccentric. They're not actually dangerous or demented. They just have a kooky little obsession that they can speak charmingly about in simple, straightforward language that either has some good audio or some good video along with it.
对。就像一个讨人喜欢的怪人。他们实际上并不危险或疯狂。他们只是有一个古怪的小执念，可以用简单、直接的语言迷人地讲述出来，并伴有好的音频或视频。
Can I ask you to read the paragraph in your manual about the ideal, wacky person?
我可以请你读一下你的手册里关于理想的古怪人的段落吗？
Yes. "The ideal, wacky person is naively unselfconscious, very enthusiastic, and deeply sincere. He or she provides a lot of unintentionally hilarious details and seems unaware that the reporter is making the best jokes. A lot of these people seem to flourish in places like the Midwest. A lot of them make it onto The Tonight Show."
好的。“理想的古怪人是天真地不自我意识、非常热情且深切真诚的。他或她提供了很多无意中搞笑的细节，并且似乎没有意识到记者正在讲最好的笑话。这些人中的许多人似乎在中西部等地茁壮成长。他们中的很多人上了《今夜秀》。”
So let's say that you do achieve this level of fame. You grab for the cheap, easy fame. Where's it get you?
那么，假设你确实达到了这种名气水平。你抓住了廉价、容易获得的名声。这能带给你什么？
The only thing that happens to you career-wise, and "career" is in big quotes, is that colleges and places will start calling you to see if you can put on one of your stunts at their school. There is no budget. Do a stunt at your own expense to draw media people for their event. So you become kind of a no-budget, publicity, wacky stunt director.
职业生涯中唯一发生的事情——“职业”要打大引号——就是学院和地方会开始打电话给你，看看你能不能在他们的学校表演你的特技。没有预算。自费做特技来为他们的活动吸引媒体。所以你变成了一种没预算的、宣传性的、古怪特技导演。
I could just see that this was not proceeding in the right fashion. So I quit. I was hoping that I would be profiled in art magazines and photographed in a black turtleneck, but that destiny never followed me when I did these pieces. It was like more a morning radio host in Kansas City would call me and say, "Sandra, are you as wacky as people say? What makes you go? Are you nutty?" So my dreams of becoming a hip, downtowny, guerrilla artist in these art books by doing these pieces faded rapidly.
我能看出这并没有按正确的方向进行。所以我退出了。我曾希望我能在艺术杂志上被介绍，并拍摄穿着黑色高领毛衣的照片，但当我做这些作品时，那种命运从未跟随我。更像是堪萨斯城的一位早间广播主持人给我打电话说：“桑德拉，你像人们说的那么古怪吗？是什么让你这么做？你疯了吗？”所以我想通过这些作品成为艺术书籍中时髦的、市中心的、游击艺术家的梦想迅速破灭了。
In fact, if you were to choose where you would end up, you couldn't actually arrive further from hip and downtown than a guy from Kansas City calling you up and saying, "Are you wacky?"
事实上，如果你可以选择最终在哪里结束，你不可能比一个堪萨斯城的家伙打电话给你说“你古怪吗？”离时髦和市中心更远。
It's true, and I think when people start out, especially when you're younger, you think it's all going to come in one incredible ball. And then, you'll be famous, and you'll get a lot of people who want to sleep with you, and great book offers, and a house in Connecticut, and all those things together. But in fact, it never comes in the right order. It never comes at the right time, and it's never the right kind of fame. And pretty much by the time you get something, in a word, it's always five years too late. And people who you don't respect have gotten it, so it cheapens it. And in fact, nothing ever feels like you think it will feel.
是真的，而且我认为当人们刚开始时，尤其是当你年轻的时候，你认为这一切会变成一个不可思议的整体。然后，你会出名，你会得到很多想和你上床的人，还有很棒的书约，在康涅狄格州的房子，所有这些加在一起。但事实上，它永远不会按正确的顺序到来。它永远不会在正确的时间到来，而且永远不是那种正确的名声。而且当你得到某种东西时，差不多也就是晚了五年。而且你不尊重的人也得到了它，所以这贬低了它。事实上，没有什么感觉是你想象的那样。
Well, thank you for these cheerful and uplifting words, Sandra Loh.
好吧，谢谢你这些欢快和鼓舞人心的话，桑德拉·罗。
Sandra Loh's book is called, Depth Takes a Holiday . No offense, please, to our listeners in Kansas.
桑德拉·罗的书叫《深度度假》。对我们堪萨斯州的听众，请不要见怪。
[MUSIC - "SHOW BUSINESS" BY A TRIBE CALLED QUEST]
[音乐 - A TRIBE CALLED QUEST的“SHOW BUSINESS”]
Act Two, Whoring in Radio News. Now, this story from the fringes of the media industries. Scott Carrier was a radio reporter in Salt Lake City who did not seek fame. He did not want to be on the cover of People magazine. He did not want to be on Johnny Carson or mentioned in the monologue. He just wanted to have a steady job with bosses who he did not hate and who did not hate him. And he found that job, for a short time, in commercial radio.
第二幕，广播新闻中的“卖身”。现在，这个来自媒体行业边缘的故事。斯科特·卡里尔曾是盐湖城的一名广播记者，他不寻求名声。他不想上《人物》杂志封面。他不想上强尼·卡森的节目或在独白中被提及。他只是想拥有一份稳定的工作，有他不讨厌、也不讨厌他的老板。他在商业广播中短暂地找到了这份工作。
There are a lot of bad ways to wake up, but surely one of the worst is by looking into the floodlight from a police car. I was in a field, some farmer's field next to a power plant just outside Lawrence, Kansas. I was sleeping there, next to my car, before driving into Kansas City in the morning. The policeman somehow saw my car from the road, and they pulled up right in front of it. And I didn't even wake up.
醒来的方式有很多种坏的，但最坏的肯定是看着警车的泛光灯。我当时在堪萨斯州劳伦斯郊外的一个发电厂旁边的农田里。我在那里睡觉，就在我的车旁边，准备早上开车去堪萨斯城。警察不知怎么从路上看到了我的车，他们直接停在它前面。我甚至没醒。
I was lying on the ground on the passenger side of the car, and when I did wake up, one of the policeman was in the front seat, I guess looking for drugs. And the other was 40 feet away in the hay field. And I don't know why he was out there, unless he had his gun pulled, covering his partner. He said I scared him when I woke up so suddenly. I sat straight up-- boom-- awake. And I bet he nearly shot me dead.
我躺在车的乘客那一侧的地上，当我醒来时，一个警察坐在前座，我想他在找毒品。另一个在40英尺外的干草地里。我不知道他为什么在那里，除非他拔出了枪，掩护他的伙伴。他说我突然醒来把他吓坏了。我猛地坐起来——砰——清醒了。我打赌他差点把我打死。
They wanted to know what I was doing sleeping in the field, and I told them that I didn't like motels, which was only partly true. So I decided to tell them that I was born here, in Lawrence, but that I don't live here anymore, which was completely true, but somehow didn't achieve the level of meaning I hoped it would. They asked me what I was going to do in Kansas City, and I said I was going to interview the mayor at 11:00 in the morning.
他们想知道我为什么在田里睡觉，我告诉他们我不喜欢汽车旅馆，这只是一部分事实。所以我决定告诉他们我是出生在这里的，在劳伦斯，但我不再住在这里了，这完全是真实的，但不知何故没有达到我希望达到的意义水平。他们问我打算在堪萨斯城做什么，我说我打算在早上11点采访市长。
I told them I was a producer for a radio program. I told them the name of the program and the name of the host, and they'd heard of him. You'd know who he is as well if I were to say his name, but I've decided not to say his name and call him The Friendly Man, instead, because this is his persona. I told the policemen that every weekday morning, The Friendly Man has a five-minute feed on one of the networks, and 12 million people listen.
我告诉他们我是广播节目的制片人。我告诉了他们节目的名字和主持人的名字，他们听说过他。如果我说出他的名字你也会知道他是谁，但我决定不说出他的名字，而是叫他“友好先生”，因为这就是他的人设。我告诉警察，每个工作日的早上，“友好先生”在网络上有一个五分钟的简报，有1200万人收听。
His stories are, as a rule, upbeat and positive. Their general theme is people taking responsibility for their lives, their community, their country. The Friendly Man always has good news, and the good news is always that America just keeps getting better and better. Both policemen said they'd heard of the program and that they like The Friendly Man. And so they decided they liked me as well, and it was OK to sleep in the field. Sorry to have bothered you.
他的故事通常是乐观和积极的。他们的总体主题是人们为自己的生活、社区和国家承担责任。友好先生总是有好消息，而好消息总是美国变得越来越好。两位警察都说他们听说过这个节目，他们喜欢友好先生。所以他们决定也喜欢我，在田里睡觉也没问题。抱歉打扰你了。
I was hired by one of The Friendly Man's executive producers. Her job was to wrangle and corral radio producers, like myself, from around the country into conducting interviews and writing scripts for stories that had been found by her flock of computer researchers, also from around the country. Some people are surprised to hear that The Friendly Man doesn't actually produce the stories he tells, but in reality, he just doesn't have the time, what with the television show now, and the specials, and so on. It's not that he doesn't want to write his stories, not that he can't, it's just that he's really busy now being The Friendly Man. And you shouldn't expect him to come up with all of his own material.
我被友好先生的一位执行制片人雇用了。她的工作是争夺和聚集像我这样的全国各地的广播制作人，去进行采访并为她的计算机研究人员团队找到的故事撰写剧本，这些研究人员也来自全国各地。有些人很惊讶地听到友好先生实际上并不制作他讲述的故事，但实际上，他只是没时间，毕竟现在有电视节目、特别节目等等。并不是他不写自己的故事，也不是他写不出来，只是他现在忙着当“友好先生”。你不应该指望他想出他所有的素材。
The way it works is that The Friendly Man is in New York with maybe a couple of editors and an engineer. And his executive producer is in San Francisco, with fax machines and email, and the researchers are all over the place looking for story ideas through computer searches. When the researcher finds what looks like an appropriate story, he calls the people in the story on the phone and talks to them for a while. Then, he writes out a story synopsis, which is sent to The Friendly Man for approval.
工作方式是，“友好先生”在纽约，也许有几个编辑和一名工程师。他的执行制片人在旧金山，有传真机和电子邮件，研究人员到处通过计算机搜索寻找故事创意。当研究人员找到看起来合适的故事时，他会给故事里的人打电话，和他们谈一会儿。然后，他写出故事大纲，发给友好先生审批。
Once approved, the story goes to a producer, and the producer is in charge of conducting, basically, the same interviews all over again, on tape this time, and then editing the tape, and writing the script, which is reviewed by the executive producer in San Francisco, and sent to The Friendly Man in New York City so he can read it on the air.
一旦批准，故事就交给制片人，制片人负责进行同样的采访，这次是录音，然后剪辑录音，并写剧本，由旧金山的执行制片人审查，并发送给纽约的友好先生，这样他就可以在广播里朗读。
The first story I produced for The Friendly Man was in Tucson, Arizona. It was about some people in Tucson who were helping to make America a better place. It doesn't really matter what the story was about. What matters is that I had to do all the interviews over the phone. There wasn't enough money to send me to Tucson.
我为友好先生制作的第一个故事是在亚利桑那州的图森。是关于一些图森的人正在帮助让美国变得更好。故事的内容并不重要。重要的是我必须通过电话完成所有的采访。没有足够的钱送我去图森。
So I found an audio engineer in Tucson and had him go to the locations and hold a microphone up to the subjects while I talked to them on the phone. Then he sent me the tape, which I edited, and then wrote the script, without ever meeting the people I was writing about or the person I was writing for. When I made a suggestion for changing the story, a change that I thought would make it better, the executive producer said that she would try not to get upset with me because this was my first story, and maybe I didn't understand my role.
所以我找了一位图森的音频工程师，让他去现场，在我和受访者通电话时把麦克风递给他们。然后他把录音发给我，我剪辑并写了剧本，从来没有见过我写的那些人，也没有见过我为之写作的人。当我提出修改故事的建议时，一个我认为会让故事变得更好的改动，执行制片人说她会尽量不生我的气，因为这是我的第一个故事，也许我不了解我的角色。
The story had been approved as written in the synopsis. There were to be no changes, no additional narratives or discoveries. I was but the writer/producer, one of many cogs in the wheel. I apologized and did the story as ordered.
故事已按照大纲批准，不得修改，不得有额外的叙述或发现。我只是个写手/制片人，轮子里的齿轮之一。我道歉并按要求做了故事。
After this first story, I asked the executive producer if I could go on the road, drive around, and collect interviews, actually meet the people and see what they were doing, and then come back and produce the stories. She gave me four stories at a distance of 3,000 miles. They'd pay the mileage, but would give me nothing up front. The food and lodging were to be my expenses, and so I was sleeping out. It was the first week of July, and so warm at night you could sleep on the grass without a bag or a blanket.
在这个第一个故事之后，我问执行制片人我是否可以上路，开车四处走走，收集采访，真正见到那些人看看他们在做什么，然后再回来制作故事。她给了我四个故事，距离3000英里。他们会支付里程费，但预付什么都不会给。食宿是我的开销，所以我睡在外面。那是7月的第一周，晚上很暖和，你可以睡在草地上而不需要睡袋或毯子。
At 11:00 AM on the morning after the incident with the police, I was standing in the mayor's office on the top floor of the Kansas City, Missouri, municipal building. It's a tall building, built on one of the highest hills in the area. So looking out of the window, I could see most of the city, buildings, and railroad tracks, and the river, the Missouri River, making a big oxbow right through town. We sat at a long, wooden table, a conference table, in tall chairs. Mayor Emanuel Cleaver, also a Methodist minister, a black mayor in a black town-- I'd come to ask him about a summertime midnight basketball program.
在与警察发生冲突的第二天上午11点，我站在堪萨斯州密苏里州市政大楼顶层的市长办公室里。这是一座高楼，建在该地区最高的山丘之一上。所以从窗户望去，我可以看到大部分城市，建筑物、铁轨，以及河流——密苏里河，穿城而过形成一个大牛轭弯。我们坐在会议桌旁，长木桌，坐在高背椅上。市长伊曼纽尔·克利弗也是一名卫理公会牧师，一个黑人城镇的黑人市长——我来问他关于暑期午夜篮球项目的事。
The program, like all midnight basketball programs, was designed to reduce the crime rate by keeping juveniles off the street. And like with some of the other programs, the crime rate hadn't gotten any better, except for the time that the kids were actually playing basketball. Whenever there was a game going on, the crime rate in the neighborhood was lower. The mayor's opponents were saying that the program was pork, that the $100,000 a year could be better spent somewhere else.
这个项目和所有的午夜篮球项目一样，旨在通过让青少年远离街道来降低犯罪率。和其他一些项目一样，犯罪率并没有好转，除了孩子们真正打篮球的时间。只要有比赛进行，附近地区的犯罪率就会降低。市长的反对者说这个项目是浪费公款，每年10万美元可以花在别的地方。
I asked the mayor about this, and he was adamant, even passionate, about the value of teaching kids to play basketball or any team sport. He said that team sports teach kids the best values, that they learn to cooperate and play by the rules. They learn to problem-solve through cooperation. And by playing, they learn to love the game. And through the love of the game, they learn to love themselves and each other.
我问市长这个问题，他非常坚定，甚至热情地谈到了教孩子们打篮球或任何团队运动的价值。他说团队运动教给孩子最好的价值观，他们学会合作并遵守规则。他们学习通过合作解决问题。通过参与，他们学会爱上这项运动。通过热爱这项运动，他们学会爱自己和彼此。
He said that a few of the kids had gone to college on basketball scholarships, and this gave hope to everybody in the community, a community where hope was like a foreign language. And that, alone, was worth it, even a bargain at $100,000. He said, you go to the games. It's mothers, fathers, sisters, brothers, you'll see the whole community there.
他说一些孩子靠篮球奖学金上了大学，这给了社区里的每个人希望，一个希望就像外语的社区。仅这一点就值了，甚至10万美元也是一笔划算的买卖。他说，你去现场看比赛。那是母亲、父亲、姐妹、兄弟，你会看到整个社区都在那里。
He was right. Over on the east side, the poor side of town, there are games going on in a community center, and the place was packed. And the games were good. Little eight and nine-year-olds passing the ball, and making plays, and running hard the whole game. They love the game. I interviewed coaches, kids, and parents, and everything was going fine. Things really were getting better and better in America.
他是对的。在东区，城市的贫民区，社区中心里正在进行比赛，那个地方挤满了人。比赛很精彩。八九岁的小孩传球，打出配合，全场努力奔跑。他们热爱这项运动。我采访了教练、孩子和家长，一切都很顺利。在美国，事情确实变得越来越好。
But then, just before I left, I was talking to a father about his son, and somebody-- I think probably a little kid-- took my three rechargeable batteries and a digital audiotape with the mayor's interview on it out of my bag and out of the building. And they were gone. The batteries were worth $250 and could be replaced, but the interview with the mayor was lost for good. Some little kid looked in my bag, and these things were like eggs in a basket. Anyone older would've just taken the bag.
但随后，就在我离开前，我正在和一个父亲谈论他的儿子，有人——我想可能是一个小屁孩——把我三个可充电电池和那份带有市长采访的数字录音带从我的包里拿走并带出了大楼。它们不见了。电池价值250美元，可以更换，但市长的采访永远丢失了。有个小屁孩往我包里看了看，这些东西就像篮子里的鸡蛋。任何大一点的人都会直接把包拿走。
I walked around the neighborhood for a while, trying to figure out what to do. The next day was a Saturday, and I doubted the mayor would be in his office, which would mean that I'd have to wait until Monday. But I had appointments for interviews Monday morning for another story in Saint Louis, 300 miles to the east. And then, there was the fact that I'd been robbed while doing a story about a program that reduces juvenile crime.
我在附近转了一会儿，试图弄清楚该怎么办。第二天是周六，我怀疑市长不在办公室，这意味着我得等到周一。但我周一早上还有另一个在圣路易斯的故事的采访预约，向东300英里。还有，我因为做关于减少青少年犯罪项目的报道而被抢了。
The story, as it was written by the researcher in the synopsis, was all about how black people were improving their lives and making things better by playing basketball. But the reality of the situation, at least the way I saw it, was that these people were poor, that they'd been for a long time, and that they were probably going to stay poor for a long time. So I called the executive producer and left her a message saying that maybe she should consider scrapping the basketball story, and that I was going on to Saint Louis, and would call her from there.
研究人员在大纲中写的故事是关于黑人如何通过打篮球改善生活并让事情变好。但现实情况，至少我看到的是，这些人很穷，他们已经穷了很长时间了，而且他们可能还要再穷很长时间。所以我给执行制片人打了电话，留了言说也许她应该考虑取消篮球故事，我要去圣路易斯了，到时候从那里打给她。
The story in Saint Louis was also about poor black people. Only in Saint Louis, it was about old poor black people. Old poor black people who lived in a nursing home and had started their own private economy, wherein they'd get paid for helping each other out by washing clothes or cooking meals, or even reading books and stories out loud at bedtime. But they didn't get paid in real money. They got paid in what they called Time Dollars, which could only be exchanged between themselves or cashed in at a special community store for food, clothing, and other necessary items.
圣路易斯的故事也是关于贫穷的黑人。只是在圣路易斯，是关于贫穷的老黑人。住在疗养院并开始了自己的私下经济的老穷黑人，在那里他们通过互相洗衣服、做饭，甚至在睡前大声朗读书籍和故事来获得报酬。但他们得到的不是真正的钱。他们得到的是所谓的“时间美元”，只能在他们之间兑换，或者在特殊的社区商店里换取食物、衣服和其他必需品。
The old people liked the Time Dollar Program. They were much happier than before they had the Time Dollar Program. At least, this is what the researcher had written in the synopsis. And this is how things seemed for most of the morning I was there doing interviews.
老人喜欢时间美元项目。他们比有时间美元项目之前快乐多了。至少，研究人员在大纲里是这么写的。在我做采访的大部分时间里，情况似乎确实如此。
My first interview was with a woman who'd set everything up. She was a well-educated, upper middle class white lady who worked for a large charitable organization as a local manager of its programs. This woman was very nervous, and I couldn't tell if it was because she was just nervous being interviewed, or if she was nervous being surrounded by poor black people, or if she was just nervous by nature.
我的第一次采访是和一位建立这一切的女士。她是一位受过良好教育、中上阶层的白人女性，为一个大型慈善组织工作，担任其项目的当地经理。这位女士非常紧张，我无法分辨是因为被采访而紧张，还是因为被贫穷的黑人包围而紧张，还是她天生就紧张。
I talked to her for a while, and then she introduced me to some women who actually participated in the Time Dollar Program. And they told me that they do things like call up old people around town and ask them if they feel OK, if they're sick or something. Or they clean and dry a neighbor's clothes before he goes into the hospital, or cook for someone who has bad asthma. And then, they could use the Time Dollars to buy stuff they needed. They were friendly ladies, and it was just like it said in the synopsis, neighbors helping neighbors and getting paid to do it.
我和她谈了一会儿，然后她把我介绍给了一些真正参与时间美元项目的妇女。她们告诉我，她们做的事情比如给城里的老人打电话，问他们感觉如何，是否生病了之类的。或者在邻居去医院前帮他清洗和晾干衣服，或者为有哮喘的人做饭。然后，她们可以用时间美元买她们需要的东西。她们是友好的女士，就像大纲里说的那样，邻居帮助邻居并为此得到报酬。
So I asked them if we could go over and see the store, the place where they actually buy everything. And they sort of hemmed and hawed about it, said there was a key, and they'd have to get it. And then we were talking about grandchildren, arthritis, the weather in Mississippi. I was wondering if maybe they didn't really want to go to the store.
所以我问她们能不能去看看商店，她们真正购买所有东西的地方。她们支支吾吾的，说有一把钥匙，她们得去拿。然后我们在聊孙辈、关节炎、密西西比的天气。我在想也许她们并不真的想去商店。
So I asked again, and they said it was a couple blocks away, and it was raining so hard. I was a little worried at this point, because the store was in the synopsis. And so there had to be some tape of the store in the story. And so I explained my predicament to the women and begged them, as best I could, if we could go there.
所以我又问了一次，她们说商店在几个街区外，雨下得太大了。我此时有点担心，因为大纲里提到了商店。所以故事里必须得有商店的录音。所以我向她们解释了我的困境，尽我所能恳求她们，看我们能不能去那儿。
We borrowed some umbrellas and walked over to the building that housed the store. It was a one-story warehouse, brick and concrete, a few windows. Inside, we went down a hallway that separated two large rooms, each packed with desks and office people, stacks of papers, stacks of folders, desk fans, lots of desk lights, people typing on real typewriters, old adding machines. It was very suspicious. One side looked like the Bulgarian Foreign Trade Department, the other side like the Lithuanian Shipping Commission.
我们借了一些雨伞，走到那家商店所在的建筑物。那是一座单层的仓库，砖石和混凝土结构，有几扇窗户。里面，我们穿过一条走廊，走廊将两个大房间隔开，每个房间都挤满了办公桌和办公人员、成堆的文件、成堆的文件夹、台式风扇、很多台灯，人们在真正的打字机和旧加法机上打字。这非常可疑。一边看起来像保加利亚外贸部，另一边看起来像立陶宛航运委员会。
Down at the far, dark end of the hall was a large metal cabinet with two full-length doors closed by a padlock. One of the ladies opened the lock, and inside were four shelves. The top held bottles of fabric softener. The next was full of baby wipes. Another had some paper plates and plastic silverware. And the bottom was full of bathroom deodorizer. That was it. That was the store.
在走廊尽头的黑暗处，有一个大的金属柜，有两扇被挂锁锁住的全长门。其中一位女士打开锁，里面有四层架子。顶层放着织物柔顺剂。下一层全是婴儿湿巾。还有一些纸盘子和塑料餐具。底部全是浴室清新剂。就这些。那就是商店。
I'd imagined something between a 7-11 and a thrift store, and I didn't understand. I didn't understand how any of this was working. I stood there and looked at the cabinet, and the story disintegrated into baby wipes and picnic forks.
我原本想象的是在7-11便利店和二手店之间的东西，我不明白。我不明白这一切是怎么运作的。我站在那里看着那个柜子，故事崩解成了婴儿湿巾和野餐叉。
I thanked the ladies and left the building, and called the executive producer. I didn't want to tell her about the baby wipes and the fabric softener. There was no use in telling her that something was wrong, that maybe the whole story was a sham. But I did want to ask her if it would be OK if I left the store out of the story, that maybe the story should be that these people just like helping each other, and that the time money thing wasn't so important. But she never let me get to it.
我感谢了女士们并离开了大楼，给执行制片人打了电话。我不想告诉她婴儿湿巾和织物柔顺剂的事。告诉她出了问题，这个故事可能是一场骗局，毫无用处。但我确实想问她，如果我把商店从故事里删掉，只说这些人喜欢互相帮助，时间金钱那回事没那么重要，可以吗？但她从来没让我说到那儿。
She was upset, very upset, about the message I'd left on her machine Friday night. It had ruined her whole weekend. She was distraught and nearly hysterical. Everyone was distraught and nearly hysterical, and it was my fault. My fault to have taken my eyes off the equipment. My fault to have been robbed. My fault to have left town without completing the story assignment.
她很生气，非常生气，关于我周五晚上在她录音机上留下的信息。这毁了她的整个周末。她心烦意乱，近乎歇斯底里。每个人都心烦意乱，近乎歇斯底里，这都是我的错。没看管好设备是我的错。被抢了是我的错。没完成故事任务就离开城镇是我的错。
She said that I'd led her to believe that I was a professional, but no professional would ever behave in such a manner. She said this twice, the subtext being that The Friendly Man can only use professional producers, and that, therefore, I was fired, unless maybe I went back to Kansas City to re-interview the mayor. My job was to do what I was told, just as their job was to do what they were told, just as The Friendly Man's job was to do what he was told. Because the audience, the 12 million listeners, had something they wanted to be told, that America is a good place with decent people. Never mind the screaming coming from the basement.
她说我让她以为我是一个专业人士，但没有专业人士会表现得那样。她说两次，潜台词是友好先生只能用专业制作人，因此，我被解雇了，除非也许我回到堪萨斯城去重新采访市长。我的工作是按命令行事，就像他们的工作是按命令行事，就像友好先生的工作是按命令行事一样。因为受众，那1200万听众，有些东西他们想被告知，那就是美国是一个有着体面人的好地方。别管从地下室传来的尖叫声。
So I got in my car and drove 300 miles west to Kansas City. I could've told them to go [BLEEP] themselves, but I didn't. I went back because I didn't want to be fired by The Friendly Man. I had been fired by other less well-known friendly men. That's always like being branded, scorned as the one who ran. I was tired of that, tired of being broke and not having any work. My wife, my family, they were tired of it too.
所以我上了车，开车向西300英里到堪萨斯城。我本来可以叫他们去[哔——]自己的，但我没有。我回去是因为我不想被友好先生解雇。我被其他不太出名的友好先生解雇过。那种感觉总是像被烙印，被轻蔑为逃跑的人。我厌倦了那样，厌倦了身无分文，没有工作。我的妻子，我的家人，他们也厌倦了。
I decided that I wanted to be a professional. I wanted to be a team player. I wanted to take responsibility for my life, my community, and my country. I wanted to get ahead and go someplace with my career, and be happy.
我决定我想成为一名专业人士。我想成为一名团队合作者。我想为我的生活、我的社区和我的国家承担责任。我想在职业生涯中取得进步，去某个地方，变得快乐。
I drove back to Kansas City and got in late at night. I drove through the big buildings downtown, the streets lit yellow and vacant. I drove through the poor neighborhoods, the streets lit yellow and vacant. I drove along the parkways, past fountains and parks, and I drove past my grandmother's house and down to The Country Club Plaza, where I slept without a bag or a blanket on the lawn, on the long esplanade in front of the Nelson Art Museum. If I was to be bothered by the police, I would tell them that I am a radio producer working for The Friendly Man and that I have a meeting with the mayor in the morning.
我开车回到堪萨斯城，深夜才到。我开过市中心高大的建筑物，街道亮着黄灯，空无一人。我开过贫民区，街道亮着黄灯，空无一人。我沿着林荫道开，经过喷泉和公园，我经过我祖母的房子，开到乡村俱乐部广场，在那里我睡在草坪上，不需要睡袋或毯子，在尼尔森艺术博物馆前的长长滨海大道上。如果警察来找麻烦，我会告诉他们我是为友好先生工作的广播制作人，早上还要见市长。
Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City. Music by Tim Rutili and Red Red Meat.
斯科特·卡里尔在盐湖城。音乐由蒂姆·鲁蒂利和红肉乐队提供。
[MUSIC - "WHO LISTENS TO RADIO?" BY SARAH VAUGHN]
[音乐 - 萨拉·沃恩的“WHO LISTENS TO RADIO?”]
Well, coming up, the least likely get-rich-quick scheme in the world, and ever, ever, ever so much more. That's all in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
好了，接下来，世界上最不可能的快速致富计划，以及更多更多更多内容。就在一分钟后，来自公共广播国际，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you radio monologues, documentaries, found tapes, anything we can think of on that theme. Today's stories are all about people on the fringe, the very edge, of our nation's media, news, entertainment industry. We've now arrived at Act Three, a small personal act.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来广播独白、纪录片、发现的录音带，任何我们能想到的关于该主题的内容。今天的故事都是关于处在边缘的人们，国家媒体、新闻、娱乐产业的最边缘。我们现在到达了第三幕，一个小小的个人行为。
Sarah Vowell is a columnist for Salon , the online magazine, author of the book Radio On , and a music writer. And she has these thoughts about the uses of music by those who are not musicians.
萨拉·沃威尔是在线杂志《沙龙》的专栏作家，图书《Radio On》的作者，也是一位音乐作家。她对那些非音乐家使用音乐的方式有一些想法。
Long distance love affair by cassette tape. It happened to me. While digital romance is growing increasingly common, our strange fling was quaintly analog. Oh, we talked on the phone for hours and enjoyed the occasional mushy rendezvous in the flesh at airports and bookstores and bars. But mostly, we wore out the heads on our respective tape decks compiling Memorex mash notes.
卡带式的异地恋。发生在我身上过。虽然数字浪漫越来越普遍，但我们那段奇怪的恋情有着古朴的模拟味道。哦，我们在电话里聊过几个小时，在机场、书店和酒吧进行过偶尔的亲密约会。但大多时候，我们是在各自的录音机上磨损磁头，编写着Memorex的“暗恋情书”。
I'm not really the scented envelope kind of girl, preferring instead to send yellow Jiffylite Mailers packed with whatever songs on my mind. The most interesting thing about the correspondence was that we rarely, if ever, agreed. He sent me this.
我真的不是那种会送香喷喷信封的女孩，我更喜欢邮寄黄色的Jiffylite信封，里面装着我脑子里想到的任何歌曲。通信中最有趣的事情是，我们几乎从不达成一致。他给我发了这个。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
I sent him this.
我给他发了这个。
[MUSIC - "IN THE FLESH" BY BLONDIE]
[音乐 - BLONDIE的“IN THE FLESH”]
He sent me this.
他给我发了这个。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
OK. I sent him this.
好吧。我给他发了这个。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Perhaps you're anticipating what I'm about to say. I think my scrappy little pop songs got on his nerves, and his ambient soundscapes left me impatient for something, anything, to happen. But I gritted my teeth through them all, groaning over every last spacey sense jam as if I was doing him some kind of personal favor. Since he went to the trouble of making the tape, the least I could do was sit there and take it. Not that I miss those songs of his-- and I use the word "songs" loosely-- since we parted ways, not by a long shot, but what I did get out of the entire, sad situation, besides big phone bills and a box of cassettes I'll never touch again, was a lingering sentimentality about the act of taping itself. A homemade tape is a work of friendship.
也许你预料到我要说什么了。我想我那些简陋的小流行歌曲让他心烦，而他的氛围音景让我等得不耐烦，急切想发生点什么，什么都行。但我咬牙坚持听完了所有，对每一个迷幻的感官音轨呻吟，好像我在帮他什么个人忙似的。既然他费心制作了磁带，我能做的至少是坐那儿接受它。我并不想念他的那些歌——我宽松地使用“歌”这个词——自从我们分道扬镳后，一点也不。但我从整个悲伤的情况中得到的，除了高昂的电话费和一箱我再也不会碰的卡带，是对录音行为本身的一种挥之不去的感伤。自制磁带是友谊的结晶。
I was reminded of that when I was reading English writer Nick Hornby's novel, High Fidelity. One of the subtexts of his story is the emotional complexities of the taping ritual. Much of the story takes place in a London record store. Clerks Barry and Dick are emotional cripples stuck in that male pop culture circle of hell, in which having seen a film, the right kind of film, or owning a record, the right kind of record, act as substitutes for being able to express what these things mean to them. Since they are incapable of really talking about human feelings, they get by on standing next to each other at rock shows and making each other complicated tapes of obscure songs.
当我读英国作家尼克·霍恩比的小说《失恋排行榜》时，我想起了这一点。故事的潜台词之一是录音仪式的复杂情感。故事大部分发生在一间伦敦唱片店。店员巴里和迪克是情感残障人士，困在那个男性流行文化的地狱循环中，在这个循环中，看过电影——那种正确的电影——或拥有一张唱片——那种正确的唱片——被当作无法表达这些东西对他们意味着什么的替代品。因为他们无法真正谈论人类情感，他们就通过站在摇滚演出旁边互相给对方制作晦涩歌曲的复杂磁带度日。
In the book, Rob, their boss at the record store, met his girlfriend, Laura, when he was a deejay at a dance club. She first approached him because she liked a song he was playing called "Got to Get You Off My Mind." Rob woos Laura by making her a compilation tape. I asked Nick Hornby to read the passage in which Rob slaves over his audio valentine.
书中，他们在唱片店的老板罗布，是在一家舞厅当DJ时遇到女友劳拉的。她第一次接近他，是因为她喜欢他放的一首歌，叫《Got to Get You Off My Mind》。罗布通过给她做精选集磁带来追求劳拉。我请尼克·霍恩比朗读罗布为他的音频情人节而苦战的那段情节。
I spent hours putting that cassette together. To me, making a tape is like writing a letter. There's a lot of erasing and rethinking and starting again. A good compilation tape, like breaking up, is hard to do.
我花了几个小时整理那盘磁带。对我来说，制作磁带就像写信。有很多擦除、重新思考和重新开始的过程。一张好的精选集磁带，就像分手一样，很难做到。
You've got to kick off with a corker to hold the attention. I started with "Got to Get You Off My Mind," but then realized she might not get any further than track one, side one if I delivered what she wanted straightaway. So I buried it in the middle of side two.
你得用一首震撼的歌开场来抓住注意力。我用《Got to Get You Off My Mind》开场，但后来意识到，如果我直接给了她想要的东西，她可能听不到第一面第一首之后。所以我把它埋在了第二面的中间。
And then you've got to up it a notch or cool it a notch. And you can't have white music and black music together, unless the white music sounds like black music. And you can't have two tracks by the same artist side by side, unless you've done the whole thing in pairs. And there are loads of rules.
然后你得提升一个档次或者冷却一个档次。而且你不能把白人音乐和黑人音乐放在一起，除非白人音乐听起来像黑人音乐。而且你不能把同一个艺术家的两首歌放在一起，除非你整盘都成对做。这有很多规则。
While I was reading Hornby's book, I happened to glance at an ad in the San Francisco Weekly that read, "I'll tape record albums for you. Reasonable rates, excellent service, pick up available. Bob." And it gave a phone number. Prostitution, that's what I thought anyway. Paying someone to make a tape for you seems a whole lot like paying someone for a kiss. I asked Nick Hornby what his music-mad, record clerks would think if they saw Bob's ad in the paper.
当我在读霍恩比的书时，我不经意间瞥了一眼《旧金山周刊》上的广告，写着：“我为你翻录专辑到磁带。价格合理，服务优良，可上门取件。鲍勃。”还留了个电话号码。卖淫，我当时就是这么想的。花钱请人为你制作磁带，看起来很像花钱买吻。我问尼克·霍恩比，他那些音乐狂人唱片店员如果看到鲍勃在报纸上的广告会怎么想。
Their public view would be that it's a terrible, awful job for a grown man to do, and why haven't all these people got their own turntables and stuff. But I think maybe they'd think secretly it was kind of a neat job, and that they'd like to sit at home all day taping other people's records.
他们的公众观点会认为，对于一个成年男人来说，这是一个可怕、糟糕的工作，为什么这些人就没有自己的唱机之类的东西。但我认为也许他们私下会觉得这是一个挺不错的活儿，他们很想整天坐在家里翻录别人的唱片。
I called the number in the ad and talked to Bob, a very nice, sane person, actually. I expressed my reservations about his work, using subtle, professional phrases such as, "What a weird job."
我打了广告上的电话，和鲍勃谈了谈，其实是一个非常友好、理智的人。我表达了我对他工作的保留意见，使用了微妙、专业的短语，比如：“多么奇怪的工作。”
In my business, what I'm doing is I'm taking music that people already own and taping it for them. I see it as providing a service that people are happy to pay for. They think it's worth the money. So I feel great and make a little money on the side, and no problem.
在我的生意里，我是在拿人们已经拥有的音乐为他们录制。我将其视为提供人们乐于付费的服务。他们觉得物有所值。所以我感觉很好，还赚点零花钱，没问题。
So Bob's business is much more, well, businesslike than I imagined. He doesn't make the kind of painstaking compilation tapes you make for someone you have a crush on.
所以鲍勃的生意比我想象的要“商务”得多。他制作的不是那种你为你暗恋的人制作的煞费苦心的精选集磁带。
Actually, people call me, and they're so delighted to find out that this service exists. They're super happy and almost not even that price sensitive.
其实，人们给我打电话，他们发现这种服务存在都非常高兴。他们超级开心，甚至对价格都没那么敏感。
Bob's rates vary depending on the quantity of taping his clients demand, but he says each tape costs, on average, about $10. I thought this sounded sort of steep, myself, but the producers of This American Life found the price quite reasonable, considering it's what they charge for their tapes, which they'd like me to remind you may be ordered by calling 312-832-3380.
鲍勃的价格取决于客户要求的录制数量，但他表示每盘磁带平均成本大约10美元。我自己觉得这听起来有点贵，但《美国生活》的制作人发现这个价格相当合理，考虑到这是他们磁带的收费标准，他们想让我提醒你，可以通过拨打312-832-3380订购。
So after mulling over the unsavory idea that someone might be willing to pay someone else good money to make a compilation tape for his or her loved one, I decided I wanted the job.
所以在思考了那个人可能愿意花大钱请别人为他或她的爱人制作精选集磁带这种令人反感的想法后，我决定要这份工作。
I had heard that my friend, Dave, has a new lady in his life. So I roped him into hiring me to make a tape for her.
我听说我的朋友戴夫生活中有了一位新女士。所以我强拉他雇我为她做一盘磁带。
Honestly, it would be a good idea. Our relationship could use--
老实说，这是一个好主意。我们的关系可以用——
You're at the tape stage?
你们到了磁带阶段了吗？
Well, it could use a spark, I guess.
嗯，我想它需要一个火花。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
So tell me about her. Let's try and get at who she is. Is she a femme fatale kind of girl, or is she more of a My Funny Valentine?
那告诉我关于她的事。让我们尝试去了解她是谁。她是那种蛇蝎美人，还是更像《My Funny Valentine》？
She's really, in a sort of a scary way, maybe too much of a carbon copy of me.
她确实，以一种有点可怕的方式，可能太多是我的翻版了。
And are you a femme fatale Dave?
你是那种蛇蝎美人型的戴夫吗？
No. I wouldn't say either one of those. It's not like a saccharine sweet kind of thing. It's kind of low key.
不。我不会说那种话。这不是一种那种甜得发腻的东西。它有点低调。
So I want to know how intense you feel about her, and I need to run some songs by you. And you tell me whether some of these songs are kind of going too far-- how ready you are to say some of this stuff. "I Want to Hold Your Hand." Are you OK with that kind of feeling?
所以我想知道你对她感觉有多强烈，我需要和你过一遍一些歌。你告诉我这些歌中的一些是否有点太过分了——你准备好说出这些东西的程度。 《I Want to Hold Your Hand》。你对那种感觉还好吗？
Sure.
当然。
OK. Let's say the Stones, "Let's Spend the Night Together."
好的。那滚石乐队的《Let's Spend the Night Together》。
Well, yeah, that's been done. Sure.
嗯，对，那个已经做过了。当然。
OK. "Kiss" by Prince.
好的。王子乐队的《Kiss》。
Yeah, that's nice.
对，那挺好的。
Frank Sinatra singing, "Love and Marriage."
弗兰克·辛纳屈唱的《Love and Marriage》。
Nah, well, yeah, no. It's not like-- I guess if we're trying to reflect the spirit of our little relationship so far, it's not like sentimental, I guess, if that makes any sense. The "I love you, I need you" kind of genre would be out, I think. I think it would be more of the upbeat, fun stuff than "Love Me Tender" kind of stuff, at this point.
不，嗯，是的，不。不是那种——我想如果我们要反映我们目前小关系的精髓，我想那不像是感伤的。我想“我爱你，我需要你”那种类型的会出局。我认为目前它应该是欢快、有趣的东西，而不是“Love Me Tender”那种东西。
Once I started making Dave's tape, I discovered something I had never suspected. Choosing the songs and their order was sweaty, arduous toil. Making a mix tape isn't like writing a letter. It's like having a job. Without love as the engine of my labor, it was not fun.
一旦我开始制作戴夫的磁带，我就发现了一些我从未怀疑过的事情。挑选歌曲和它们的顺序是汗流浃背、艰苦的工作。制作混音磁带不像写信。就像有一份工作。没有爱作为我劳动的引擎，这真的一点都不好玩。
And I discovered something else. I did not want to follow Dave's instructions. Sure, I had worked in the service industry before, and I understood its abiding principle, "the customer is always right." At first, I was committed to following Dave's wish not to get too sentimental. But I don't know if you've listened to much popular music recorded in the last, oh half century, but it's pretty gushy stuff. Even though Dave hired me to choose love songs that didn't say, "I love you," there aren't that many out there. And even if there were, I'm fully confident that his desire for them is dead wrong. My reasoning-- he's a boy, I'm a girl, I know better.
而且我发现了别的事。我不想遵循戴夫的指示。当然，我以前在服务业工作过，我理解它一贯的原则：“顾客永远是对的”。起初，我致力于遵循戴夫不要太感伤的意愿。但我不知道你是否听过过去，哦，半个世纪里录制的大量流行音乐，它们是非常感性的东西。尽管戴夫雇我挑选不讲“我爱你”的情歌，但外面没那么多。即使有，我也完全相信他对那些歌的渴望是死错的。我的理由——他是男孩，我是女孩，我更了解。
Certainly, in making the tape, I exercised restraint. After all, they've only been together for two months. We want to reassure her, not scare her off. I steered clear of the heavies, avoiding the serious courtship crooner, Al Green, and vetoing Elvis, who should, in my opinion, only be employed when you really mean it. And when I did invoke Sinatra, I played it safe, not "Taking a Chance on Love," or even "I've Got a Crush on You," picking, instead, cheerful, subtle "Let's Get Away From It All" as a low-key, "you and me baby, just the two of us out of town" sort of thing.
当然，在制作磁带时，我行使了克制。毕竟，他们才在一起两个月。我们要让她安心，而不是吓跑她。我避开了重磅炸弹，避开了严肃的求爱歌手阿尔·格林，否决了猫王——依我之见，他只应该在你真正认真的情况下去使用。当我确实引用辛纳屈时，我打安全牌，不选《Taking a Chance on Love》，甚至《I've Got a Crush on You》，而是选择了欢快、微妙的《Let's Get Away From It All》，作为一种低调的，“我和你亲爱的，只有我们两个离开小镇”之类的东西。
[SINGING] Let's grab a kayak to Quincy or Nyack. Let's get away from it all.
[演唱] 让我们抓一艘皮划艇去昆西或尼亚克。让我们远离这一切。
Cole Porter's "Let's Do It" found a place too, but I went with urbane jokester Noel Coward's Live in Las Vegas rendition in which he moons, "Each man out there shooting craps does it. Davy Crockett in that dreadful cap does it." Still, despite Dave's "hold the sugar" request, the word "love" does pop up something like 98 times over the course of the tape. So I dropped off the tape at his house, and the next day, we got together to talk about it.
科尔·波特的《Let's Do It》也找到了一席之地，但我选了都市笑匠诺埃尔·考沃德在拉斯维加斯的现场演绎版，他在其中呻吟道：“外面每一个掷骰子的人都在做。大卫·克罗基特戴着那顶可怕的帽子也在做。”尽管如此，尽管戴夫有“别加糖”的要求，但在磁带的过程中，“爱”这个词确实出现了98次左右。所以我把磁带留在他家，第二天，我们见面谈了谈。
So Dave, you have the tape. What do you think?
好了戴夫，你有磁带了。你觉得怎么样？
I do. I like the tape a lot, personally.
我有。我个人非常喜欢这张磁带。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, I like it a lot. There isn't really anything that I don't really like.
是啊，我很喜欢它。真的没有什么我不喜欢的东西。
I don't know if you noticed or not, but I sort of ditched your instructions. Because you told me not to be too sentimental, and to keep it light and upbeat.
我不知道你注意到了没有，但我有点抛弃了你的指示。因为你告诉过我不要太感伤，要保持轻松欢快。
I thought it was light.
我认为它很轻松。
The word "love" is used a lot. It's bandied about, let's say. Yesterday, you said quote, "'The I love you, I need you' genre would be out."
“爱”这个词用了很多次。可以说被到处使用了。昨天，你说过引述：“‘我爱你，我需要你’类型会出局”。
I did, and I don't know where they say that in this--
我是说了，我不知道他们在哪说那个在这一——
In the song?
在歌里？
--tape. Do they? It's still all kind of light.
——磁带。他们说了吗？它还是挺轻松的。
"I love you" is certainly in there.
“我爱你”肯定在里面。
Where?
在哪？
Let's see.
让我看看。
Really? I don't think it is.
真的吗？我不觉得有。
I think it is.
我觉得有。
I don't think it is.
我不觉得有。
[SINGING] I need you. Come on. I love you. Come on. I need you.
[演唱] 我需要你。来吧。我爱你。来吧。我需要你。
This song is on the tape, along with Chic's "Give Me the Lovin'" and James Brown's "Hot- I Need to Be Loved, Loved, Loved." I don't know what he's talking about. Anyway, the argument might be moot.
这首歌在磁带上，还有Chic的《Give Me the Lovin'》和詹姆斯·布朗的《Hot- I Need to Be Loved, Loved, Loved》。我不知道他在说什么。无论如何，争论可能是徒劳的。
We got in some kind of fight this morning. So I haven't--
我们今天早上吵架了。所以我还没有——
You got into a fight this morning about another issue?
你们今天早上因为另一个问题吵架了？
Yeah, a different thing. So she hasn't seen this.
是啊，另一件事。所以她还没看到这个。
So now you need a tape.
所以现在你需要一盘磁带。
Yeah, maybe. I don't know what's up actually.
是啊，也许吧。其实我不知道怎么回事。
Don't spoil my narrative here Dave. See what happens is you give her the tape. She falls for you even more, and she forgives you for all of your trespasses, past and future, knowing you. And this kind of saves your relationship, and you live happy ever after.
别破坏我的叙事，戴夫。看看会发生什么，你把磁带给她。她会更爱你，她会原谅你所有过去的和未来的过错，了解你。这会在某种程度上挽救你们的关系，然后你们从此过上了幸福快乐的生活。
I like it. OK.
我喜欢它。好的。
That's what happens.
事情就是这样。
That would have happened if he had made the tape himself. Unfortunately, he's just enough of a bad boyfriend to pay someone to make a tape, but not enough of a bad boyfriend to lie about it. She already knows where that tainted cassette comes from, and it's not going to save their romance.
如果他自己制作磁带，那就会发生这种情况。不幸的是，他是个够坏的男朋友，花钱请别人做磁带，但还没坏到撒谎的程度。她已经知道那盘受污染的卡带是从哪来的了，它救不了他们的浪漫。
As for me, I'm getting out of this dirty business. Don't call the radio station inquiring about my services. Save your $10. Consider me reformed.
至于我，我要退出这个肮脏的生意了。不要打电话到电台询问我的服务。省下你的10美元吧。把我视为改过自新的人。
See if I ever give it to her though.
不过看看我会不会给它她。
You're not going to give it to her, Dave?
你不打算给它她，戴夫？
I will. I will, I guess. I'll give it to her. It's actually a really good tape. If I had made it, it probably would mean a lot. Does that make sense?
我会的。我会的，我想。我会给她的。实际上这是一盘非常好的磁带。如果是我做的，它可能意味着很多。这有意义吗？
Yes, it does. That's why you hired me.
是的，有意义。这就是你雇我的原因。
Right. You can be the buffer.
对。你可以当缓冲。
Because I have the guts to tell her what you feel--
因为我有胆量告诉她你的感受——
That's exactly it.
完全就是这样。
--even if you don't.
——即使你没有。
[MUSIC - "MIX TAPE" BY THE NONCE]
[音乐 - THE NONCE的“MIX TAPE”]
Act Four. This story of near proximity to the news, media, entertainment, megalith industry comes from Chicago writer and performer Cheryl Trykv.
第四幕。这个关于接近新闻、媒体、娱乐巨头行业的故事来自芝加哥作家和表演者谢丽尔·特里夫。
It's just a week or two before sixth grade graduation. My parents decide to celebrate early with a weekend family trip, just the three of us. I tell them to save their money. I'm not interested. They insist that all my hard work should be rewarded. "Yeah?" I say. "Then buy me a horse."
那是六年级毕业前一两周。我的父母决定提前庆祝，进行一次周末家庭旅行，只有我们三个人。我告诉他们省省钱吧。我不感兴趣。他们坚持认为我所有的努力工作都应该得到回报。“是吗？”我说。“那就给我买匹马。”
My mother smiles, sips her martini and tells me, "Spoilsports are unattractive." I tell her I'm not a spoilsport. I just don't feel like spending the weekend trapped with the same old parents I live with every day. I tell them it doesn't sound like much of a reward at all. As a matter of fact, it sounds more like punishment. I say if they really want to reward me, they'd go away themselves and leave me at home, where I could stay up late and watch Dick Cavett if I wanted.
我的母亲微笑着，抿了一口马提尼，告诉我说：“扫兴的人是没人喜欢的。”我告诉她我不是扫兴的人。我只是不想花周末时间被困在和我每天住在一起的同一个老父母身边。我告诉他们这听起来一点也不像回报。事实上，听起来更像是惩罚。我说如果他们真的想奖励我，他们就该自己走开，把我留在家里，这样我就可以晚点睡觉，如果我想的话，还可以看迪克·卡维特。
My father becomes irritated. He tells me to go to my room and not come out until I decided on a place the three of us could go and all have a good time. In my room, I draw on my sketchbook pictures of a beautiful me riding a flying horse up and away from my parents who had shackled themselves to a wet bar. My mother's face is tired and pleading, as my father teases her empty glass with a bottle of Wild Turkey.
我的父亲变得烦躁。他叫我回房间，直到决定好我们三个人可以去一个都能玩得开心的地方之前不要出来。在我的房间里，我在速写本上画了画，画的是一个美丽的我在骑着一匹飞马，远离了那些把自己锁在吧台旁的父母。我母亲的脸疲惫而恳求，我父亲用一瓶狂火鸡威士忌戏弄她空荡荡的玻璃杯。
I listen to the radio, rearrange my closet. At dinner time, I return to my parents and tell them I decided, very carefully, that San Francisco seems a reasonable choice. We could drive there from our little home in Los Angeles in just under a day, if they were careful not to lollygag. The route is scenic, and they could visit Alcatraz while I took in the Ripley's Believe It or Not Museum. Later, we could all meet for lunch on the wharf.
我听着收音机，重新整理我的壁橱。晚餐时间，我回到父母身边，告诉他们我决定了，非常仔细地决定了，旧金山似乎是个合理的选择。只要他们不磨蹭，我们可以在不到一天的时间里从我们在洛杉矶的小家开车到那儿。路线风景优美，他们可以参观恶魔岛，而我可以逛逛“信不信由你”博物馆。晚些时候，我们可以都在码头碰面吃午餐。
My mother looks at my father. She looks down at her hands and smiles at them. My father says he's sorry, but that I'd taken too long to decide and that arrangements have already been made. We'd be staying for the weekend at Aunt Rita's place in Palm Springs while she was away in Hawaii.
我母亲看着我父亲。她低头看着自己的手，冲它们微笑。我父亲说他很抱歉，但我花的时间太长了，安排已经定好了。我们周末会住在姨妈丽塔在棕榈泉的地方，因为她去夏威夷了。
Palm Springs? I tell them I'm not going to Palm Springs. The place is a cemetery, and I'd rather go to Hell. My father tells me to watch my mouth. My mother looks up from her hand and stares off into the space just over my head.
棕榈泉？我告诉他们我不去棕榈泉。那个地方是个墓地，我宁愿去地狱。我父亲叫我注意言辞。我母亲从她的手上抬起头，凝视着我头顶上方的一片虚空。
"Aunt Rita has a pool, dear." "We have a pool here, Mommy." I tell them I'm not going to Palm Springs. I'm going to San Francisco. End of story.
“丽塔姨妈有游泳池，亲爱的。”“我们这儿也有游泳池，妈妈。”我告诉他们我不去棕榈泉。我要去旧金山。故事结束。
When we get to Palm Springs, we take the tram ride up into the San Jacinto Mountains where there is still snow on the ground. My mother calls it "a miracle of nature that one minute we'd be in the middle of a blazing desert, and the next minute, up high in the mountains where gentle beds of snow lingered bravely under God's mighty sun." I call the place "a waste of time."
当我们到达棕榈泉时，我们坐有轨电车上了圣哈辛托山，地上还有积雪。我母亲称之为“大自然的奇迹，前一分钟我们还在烈日灼灼的沙漠中央，下一分钟就在山上，温和的雪床勇敢地在上帝强大的太阳下留存”。我称那个地方为“浪费时间”。
For lunch, we eat at Trader Vic's. At Aunt Rita's, Dad takes a nap on the living room couch while Mother and I change into our bathing suits. I swim for a bit in the pool, then rest on a patio lounge next to my mother who is groggy and only half awake.
午餐，我们在Trader Vic's吃饭。在丽塔姨妈家，爸爸在客厅的沙发上打盹，妈妈和我换上了泳衣。我在游泳池里游了一会儿，然后躺在妈妈旁边的露台躺椅上，她昏昏沉沉，半梦半醒。
"Oh, my," she says. "It certainly is an oven out here." "What did you expect?" She leans over and asks me in a throaty whisper if I know who lives on the other side of the hedge that runs along the far side of the yard.
“哦，天哪，”她说。“这儿确实是个烤箱。”“你以为会怎样？”她俯身，用嘶哑的低语问我，知不知道谁住在沿着院子远端的那道树篱的另一边。
"How should I know?" I say. "Shirley Booth," she says. "Shirley Booth? Who's that supposed to be?" She tells me Shirley Booth is a famous actress. "If she's so famous, how come I've never heard of her?"
“我怎么会知道？”我说。“雪莉·布斯，”她说。“雪莉·布斯？那又是谁？”她告诉我雪莉·布斯是位著名的女演员。“如果她那么出名，我怎么从没听说过她？”
"Shirley Booth is the actress who played Hazel on TV, dear." "Oh, her. I know her. She's not so famous. Vivian Vance is more famous than her."
“雪莉·布斯就是电视上扮演Hazel的女演员，亲爱的。”“哦，她啊。我知道她。她没那么出名。薇薇安·凡斯比她出名多了。”
My mother leans back down into her chaise and places her tall bourbon and water between her legs and closes her eyes. I go inside for a ginger ale. Off the kitchen at Aunt Rita's is a service porch with a door leading into the garage. I open the door and peek around. I find a three-speed Schwinn bicycle with large metal cargo baskets over each side of the back wheel.
我母亲重新躺回到躺椅上，把她的高杯波本威士忌和水放在两腿之间，闭上眼睛。我进去喝姜汁汽水。丽塔姨妈家的厨房外面是一个服务门廊，有一扇门通往车库。我打开门，四处看了看。我发现了一辆Schwinn三速自行车，后轮两侧装有巨大的金属货篮。
It's an old lady's bike, but I check it for flats and take it out for a spin. The neighborhood is quiet. It sizzles with quiet, like the quiet baking soda makes on a grease fire. It's hot, maybe 110, but I don't care. I'm devil-may-care in the belly of Hell. I'm free.
这是一辆老太太的车，但我检查了一下没漏气，就骑出去兜风了。附近很安静。那种安静滋滋作响，就像小苏打在油脂火上发出的声音。天气很热，可能110度，但我不在乎。我在地狱的肚子里也是天不怕地不怕。我自由了。
I turn up a street named Vista Mirage and imagine myself starring in a made-for-TV movie called "Teen Getaway." As I ride, I look back over my shoulder as if someone were chasing me. "Where you going to run to," I ask myself. "Lost in a ghost town or a town of fools, why is she running? Nobody knows. 'Teen Getaway'."
我拐进了一条叫“维斯塔海市蜃楼”的街道，想象自己主演了一部名为《青少年逃跑》的电视电影。骑行时，我回头看了一眼，好像有人在追我。“你要跑到哪里去，”我问自己。“迷失在鬼城或愚人的城镇里，她为什么要跑？没人知道。《青少年逃跑》。”
Somebody's front yard is a rock garden with red and green yard elves peeping through clusters of poinsettia, their faces curly and prankish. The wind is at my back, and I coast around another corner and down another street. I'm on the run. I pass new housing under construction and imagine, "This may be where I will need to camp for the night."
某人的前院是一个岩石花园，红色的和绿色的院子精灵透过一簇簇圣诞红窥视，它们的脸扭曲而调皮。风在我身后，我绕过另一个拐角，顺着另一条街道滑行。我在逃亡中。我经过正在施工的新住宅，想象着，“这可能是我今晚露营的地方。”
After a bit, it occurs to me as I ride that I should've checked the time before leaving Aunt Rita's or changed into a tee shirt or shorts, or at least put on a pair of shoes. I feel naked riding a bike in public wearing only my swimsuit, no one around in their swimsuit to make me feel less nude. The sun bakes the top of my head, burns my lips and I'm thirsty. So I circle back.
过了一会儿，我骑行时想到，离开丽塔姨妈家之前应该检查一下时间，或者换上T恤或短裤，至少穿上一双鞋。我觉得在公共场合骑自行车只穿着泳衣很裸露，周围没有人穿泳衣让我感到不那么赤身裸体。太阳烤着我的头顶，烧着我的嘴唇，我很渴。所以我绕了回来。
I'm not sure what street I'm on. I circle left and cut through the construction site. The path I take leads out into an open stretch of desert highway. A station wagon filled with boys wearing baseball uniforms drives by and honks. One of the boys leans out the window and howls like a wild coyote. "Stupid little coyote boy, go ahead. Laugh." Out in the heat of the day, riding a goofy old lady's bike, nude, not even wearing a hat, I feel like an idiot and circle back.
我不确定我在哪条街上。我向左转，穿过建筑工地。我走的路径通向一片开阔的沙漠高速公路。一辆坐满了身穿棒球服男孩的旅行车经过，按着喇叭。其中一个男孩从车窗探出身子，像野狼一样嚎叫。“愚蠢的小狼男孩，随你去吧。笑吧。”在炎炎夏日，骑着一辆傻乎乎的老太太车，赤身裸体，甚至没戴帽子，我觉得自己像个白痴，又绕了回来。
My head hurts from the sun, and I'm tired and thirsty. And now, I have to go to the bathroom also. A terrible, hot wind blows against me, and the gears on the bike seem to be stuck in third. Each street winds, and bends, and twists, and it seems that every other one of them is a cul-de-sac with a sign posted reading, "No way out."
我的头在太阳下疼，又累又渴。现在，我还得去洗手间。一阵可怕的热风吹向我，自行车上的档位似乎卡在了三档。每条街道蜿蜒曲折，扭动，似乎每隔一条就是个死胡同，挂着写有“此路不通”的牌子。
I feel weak, like I might collapse in the heat and blister to death. My mouth is dry. "Can't get no spit." I remember Mr. [? Pallone ?] at school telling the class that if we were ever lost at sea and dying of thirst, the only chance we'd have of surviving was to drink our own blood or urine. The class booed the choices, and Mr. [? Pallone ?] threw his head back and laughed and said, "Take your pick."
我感觉虚弱，好像可能会在酷热中虚脱，起泡而死。我的嘴很干。“吐不出一点口水。”我记得学校里的帕隆先生告诉班上同学，如果我们迷失在海上，渴得要死，我们生存的唯一机会就是喝自己的血或尿。全班对这些选择发出嘘声，帕隆先生仰头大笑，说：“你们自己选吧。”
I passed the yard elves again and can hear them laughing and chanting, "Drink your pee. Drink your pee." I keep riding and wonder if I should try it, seeing as it would serve a dual purpose, but can't quite picture in my mind how it would happen.
我再次经过院子里的精灵，能听到它们在笑并齐声念叨：“喝你的尿。喝你的尿。”我继续骑着，琢磨着是否应该试试，毕竟这会有双重目的，但脑子里实在无法想象那会是怎么发生的。
I imagine how embarrassed I'd be when they find me, heaped over on the side of the road in some whacked out, hooey guru, yoga position, dead and wet in a puddle of pee. A tarantula would be crawling out of my mouth also when they found me. And I imagine they'd bury me right here in Palm Springs on a lonely plot of desert. And what a mystery it would be when my grave was covered all year round with a gentle bed of snow.
我想象如果他们发现我该有多尴尬，倒在路边，以某种扭曲的、胡扯的古鲁瑜伽姿势，死得透透的，泡在尿里。他们发现我时，一只狼蛛还会从我嘴里爬出来。我想他们会把我直接埋在这棕榈泉的一块孤独的沙漠地块里。当我终年被温和的雪床覆盖时，那该是个多大的谜啊。
I see my parents crying as the camera pans out from my grave. The TV credits for "Teen Getaway" roll up the screen in my mind, and I see that Linda Purl has played me. Someone named Hitch was a gaffer, and soft and handsome, I hear the voice of Glen Campbell sing the theme song to the story of me.
我看到我的父母哭了，摄像机从我的坟墓拉远。我脑海中《青少年逃跑》的电视字幕滚过屏幕，我看到琳达·珀尔扮演了我。一个叫希奇的人是灯光师，温柔而英俊，我听到格伦·坎贝尔的声音唱着关于我故事的主题曲。
In a panic, I ride up somebody's lawn and can't stop without falling off the bike, my legs are so trembly and weak. I run to the door, ring the bell. No answer. I run to the next house, ring the bell, knock on the door. "Dammit! Answer, somebody!"
在恐慌中，我骑上某人的草坪，双腿颤抖虚弱，没法停下来不从车上摔下去。我跑到门口，按响门铃。没人回答。我跑到下一家，按门铃，敲门。“该死！谁来应门啊！”
An old woman comes to the door. It's Hazel. [LAUGHTER] I'm delirious, laughing and crying at the same time, so happy to see the face of a woman who looks so kind. I've never seen a kinder face. I tell her I've gotten lost on my bike, and I'm thirsty and need to use her bathroom. "Oh, my," she says, "come in."
一位老妇人来到门口。是Hazel。[笑声] 我陷入了神志不清，又笑又哭，看到一张看起来如此善良的女性面孔，我感到如此高兴。我从未见过更善良的脸。我告诉她我在骑车时迷路了，我很渴，需要用用她的洗手间。“哦，天哪，”她说，“进来吧。”
"Come in." The words so carefully chosen, so simple, so meaningful, so correct. "Come in," as if to say, "Hello, little friend, brave bird of passage, welcome. You have landed. Come, let me foster your repair."
“进来吧。”这几个词选择得如此小心，如此简单，如此有意义，如此正确。“进来吧，”好像在说，“你好，小朋友，勇敢的过客鸟，欢迎。你已经着陆了。来吧，让我帮帮你。”
She takes me and leads me down a cool hall to a small guest bathroom with little shell soaps and tells me to take my time. And I cry and pray as I wash my hands and feet, and splash water on my face. "Thank God for her," I say to myself. "God bless Hazel."
她带着我走进一条凉爽的走廊，去了一个带有小贝壳香皂的小客用洗手间，告诉我不必着急。当我在洗手和脚、往脸上泼水时，我哭着祈祷。“感谢上帝，”我对自己说。“上帝保佑Hazel。”
When I come out of the bathroom, I find Shirley Booth in the kitchen slicing lemons. "Do you take lemon in your water," she asks me. "Yes, I do," I say, never having tried it before. "Are you Shirley Booth?" "That's me," she says, and invites me into her living room where we sit and drink our waters next to a large aquarium filled with tropical fish.
当我走出洗手间时，我发现雪莉·布斯在厨房里切柠檬。“你喝水要加柠檬吗？”她问我。“是的，加，”我说，以前从未试过。“你是雪莉·布斯吗？”“正是我，”她说，邀请我进她的客厅，我们在那坐着，喝着水，旁边是一个装满热带鱼的大鱼缸。
I tell her about my idea for "Teen Getaway." "That's a snappy idea for a TV film." Snappy idea, how playful. Coming from my mother, "snappy idea" would only sound spastic, but coming from Hazel, the words are fresh and reinforcing. "That's a snappy idea for a TV film," as if to say, "Teen Getaway, yes! You should go with that!"
我告诉她关于《青少年逃跑》的构思。“那是拍电视电影的一个好点子。”好点子，多么俏皮。如果是我母亲说，“好点子”只会听起来像痉挛，但从Hazel口中说出，这些词新鲜而具有强化作用。“那是拍电视电影的一个好点子，”好像在说，“《青少年逃跑》，是的！你应该就拍那个！”
We sit and talk about New York City and American theater. We talk about Hollywood, and movies, and the whole business. I ask her if the rumors I'd heard about Joan Crawford and Lucille Ball being lezzie lovers were true. She says she hadn't heard that, but that once, at a party for then Governor Reagan, Lucille Ball was drunk and tossed a grape down Shirley Booth's bosom. [LAUGHTER] We laugh. "That's a good one," I say.
我们坐在一起聊纽约和美国戏剧。我们聊好莱坞、电影以及整个行业。我问她关于我听说过的琼·克劳馥和露西尔·鲍尔是女同性恋者的传言是否属实。她说她没听说过，但有一次，在当时的里根州长举办的派对上，露西尔·鲍尔喝醉了，把一颗葡萄扔进了雪莉·布斯的胸口。[笑声] 我们大笑。“那个笑话不错，”我说。
On my way out, I thank Shirley Booth for letting me in. She says it was all her pleasure and thanked me for stopping by. What luck, knocking on Hazel's door like that. If the first door I'd knocked on had answered, it would have been some anonymous old man who would have told me there was a hose on the side. His wife would've let me in, but their house would have smelled like a cat box. And while I was in the bathroom, she would have peeked her little head in and asked if everything was all right. Her lips would be covered with frosted pink lipstick and white sugar from a powdered doughnut. But Shirley's lips are pretty, like the cherry lips of a friendly elf.
离开时，我感谢雪莉·布斯让我进去。她说这是她的荣幸，并感谢我顺道拜访。多么幸运啊，敲开Hazel的门就是这样。如果我敲的第一扇门有人应答，那会是一个匿名的老头，他会告诉我在旁边有根水管。他妻子也许会让我进去，但他们家会闻起来像个猫砂盆。当我上洗手间时，她会探出小脑袋问一切是否还好。她的嘴唇会涂满霜状的粉红色口红，沾着甜甜圈上的白糖。但雪莉的嘴唇很漂亮，就像友好精灵的樱桃嘴唇一样。
I bike around the block to Aunt Rita's. The car out front is gone, but a note from my father says he's left to play golf. My mother is passed out in the den.
我骑车绕过街区回到丽塔姨妈家。门外的车不见了，但我父亲留了一张字条说他去打高尔夫球了。我母亲在书房里昏过去了。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The fabulous Cheryl Trykv.
精彩的谢丽尔·特里夫。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Peter Clowney and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Other production help from Julie Snyder, Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus.
好吧，我们的节目今天由阿里克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，彼得·克劳尼和南希·厄普代克协助。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。其他制作协助来自朱莉·斯奈德、豪尔赫·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯。
[ACKNOWEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. You know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website at www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买本节目的卡带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，312-832-3380。你知道你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢管理该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who reminds you please do not--
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他提醒你请不要——
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories from This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI,
PRI，
Public Radio International.
公共广播国际。